[Musik]
das podcast ist platin blm unique ich
begrüße sie meine damen und herren es
geht weiter mit kapitalismuskritik und
philosophie jetzt die dritte
veranstaltung
ich möchte heute weitermachen mit dem
bürgerlichen theorien des kapitalismus
aber gleichzeitig um vorneweg
ein überblick versuchen über das was man
überhaupt am kapitalismus kritisieren
könnte also es ist natürlich sehr viel
aber ich denke es wird uns helfen wenn
wir bestimmte kategorien aufstellen
okay nun aber zuerst was ist überhaupt
also versuchen nochmal einen anlauf was
ist jetzt kapital also man geht glaube
ich ein bisschen davon aus ja
kapitalismus bei deutlich was schlecht
ist und sollte abgeschafft werden aber
das ist jetzt nicht natürlich die
einstellung der kritiker mit denen wir
zu tun haben oder naja bedingt
ausgangspunkt zumindest bis
einschließlich marx und ich denke auch
pkt
als moderne vertreter der
kapitalismuskritik ist das kapital
positiv so gewichten ist also kapital
muss es geben
die frage ist wie man mit kapital
umgehen ok jetzt was ist dann dieses
kapital
ich habe schon gewissermaßen die
grundlagen für dieses neue
philosophische denken zum zur frage was
ist kapital also kapital wie wir es also
quartal zunächst mal ist ist das was wir
uns erschaffen
als unternehmer wenn wir zur bank gehen
und uns die mittel holen um maschinen zu
kaufen
räume anzumieten angestellten
anzustellen und weiter also das ist
kapital im allgemeinen sinne
kapitalisten weiterhin sind diese räume
diese maschinen sind auch die
qualifizierten arbeiter und so weiter
das ist dann realisiert das kapital gut
aber eben der ausgangspunkt für diese
fragestellung ist zunächst mal mit lok
der gedanke das kapital aus arbeit
entspringt also kapital ist nicht
einfach das was so quasi um liegt es
sind nicht die natürlichen gegebenheiten
sondern kapital wird er arbeitet kapital
besteht aus den früchten der arbeit
das ist der wichtigste punkt und das ist
etwas was bei lok es hat mir letzte
woche gesehen sehr stark betont wird die
menschen sind gleich darin dass sie
arbeiten können und diese gleichheit ist
fundamental dann für das entstehen von
reichtum oder anders gesagt von kapital
oder dies die älteren denke alle
bezeichnen als doc bekommen stock also
vorrat
das ist der erste punkt und der zweite
punkt dann bei adam smith es braucht ein
bisschen mehr als nur erarbeitete
gegenstände
sie müssen auch austauschbar
bausparen exchange der erste punkt ist
also arbeit was überhaupt die quelle und
ursprung von kapital fähigen
gegenständen ist und zweitens müssen
diese gegenstände tauscht sein exchange
labour and straight
dann da somit definiert john stuart mill
mit dem wir uns ein bisschen intensiver
beschäftigen werden das ist so ein
linksliberaler sagen wir mal philosoph
mitte des 19 jahrhunderts dessen
grundsätze der politischen ökonomie im
gleichen jahr erschienen ist
sachsens kommunistisches manifest
nämlich 48 148 will wie gesagt ein
linksliberaler den man heutzutage
durchaus mit weil sie auch bürgerlichen
systemen wie in deutschland mit der
sozialen marktwirtschaft vergleichen
könnte also nicht besonders links aber
auch nicht irgendwie manchester
kapitalismus oder kapitalismus im sinne
einiger amerikanischer denker zurzeit
okay also militarist oder folgt der
tradition der gitarristen okay also er
definiert die inhalte von käfern
kapitals in erster stock previously lake
city product for labour also da fängt er
auf das was wir schon bei lok hatten
nämlich kapital ist sie ist sind die
früchte vorausgegangener arbeit also
kapital das ist ein motiv das auch sehr
wichtig ist quasi metaphysisch kapital
entspringt der vergangenheit ist eine
übernahme aus der vergangenheit aus
vergangener arbeit das kann man positiv
oder auch negativ gewesen also wie wir
wissen später sagen leute sagen denker
wie walter benjamin und andere
kapital ist gerade die tyrannei der
vergangenheit die last der vergangenheit
gut im kapital das kann man positiv oder
negativ sehen aber jedenfalls ohne
unmittelbar sich damit zu befassen mit
diesen kritikpunkt ist kapital das was
die früchte der vergangenen arbeit in
die gegenwart hin überträgt und
verfügbar gemacht weil sonst wären sie
nicht verfügbar
kapital ist die verfügbarkeit von
vergangener arbeit ja und das ist etwas
das ist der erste grundsätzliche punkt
beim für das kapital der zweite punkt
wie gesagt ist exchange die exchange for
the saints
ok also das ist jetzt diese
austauschbarkeit das wiederum beruft
sich auf endlich einen wichtigen passus
bei dem es oft zitiert auch von hannah
arendt beispielsweise wonach der mensch
quasi definiert wird als mensch der
tausch also ein mensch ist einer der
handels handel und tausch gehört zum
wesen des menschen laut rettungs mit ja
und weil der mensch diese eigenschaft
hat entstehen handelbare waren
das ist so quasi einer natur gegebenheit
bei menschen das ist auch der
unterschied zwischen menschen und tieren
tiere machen sowas nicht also in smiths
beispiel kein und tauscht seinen knochen
gegen den anderen knochen mitten anderen
hund also das gibt es nicht aber
menschen tauschen ständig
und diese diese fähigkeit oder neigung
zum tauschen beruht auf der fähigkeit
abstrakte äquivalenten zu schaffen
das ist etwas was wir dann später bei
lukas und adorno sehr stark
durchleuchtet finden werden also die
möglichkeit abstrakter äquivalent zu
finden
das ist dann nicht nur ja ich habe jetzt
brot und du hast schuhe lasst uns
tauschen sondern die fähigkeit viel
abstraktere äquivalente also brot und
schuhe in dem zusammenhang könnten
miteinander gleichwertig oder äquivalent
sein aber der mensch im zuge dieser
vorarbeiten für die für das kapital
sozusagen entwickelt viel abstrakter
äquivalenten die natürlich dann auf dem
markt ihre systematisierung oder ihre
umsetzung finden
also das sind die zwei elemente quasi
naturgegeben eigenschaften des menschen
also das ist die würde zum schicksal des
menschen gewissermaßen arbeitgeber und
tausch extrem und aus diesen
naturgegebenen eigenschaften entwickelt
sich dann der dritte punkt die dritte
das zum kapital unbedingt dazugehört
nämlich akkumulation ansammlung also das
was ich erarbeite und tauschen kann
führt dazu oder kann jedenfalls dazu
führen dass sich akkumulieren und das
ist die dritte wesentliche voraussetzung
für kapital also wenn ich nix
akkumuliert habe quasi in der tasche
oder vorrätig habe dann kann ich auch
auf kapital basierter basis kein
beispielsweise kein unternehmen gründen
also das ist eine
unterscheidung die mit der wir später
uns beschäftigen werden
die unterscheidung zwischen dem was der
mensch zum konsum sich erarbeitet oder
irgendwie erhält und und dem was darüber
hinausgeht
also was über die konsumbedürfnisse
hinausgeht das ereignet sich zur
akkumulation von kapital sparen sparen
sparen also dass dieser begriff ist für
smith sehr wichtig also aus dem aus der
fähigkeit zu akkumulieren und sparen
daraus ergibt sich kapital also das sind
dann die logischen voraussetzungen und
theologischen voraussetzungen für
kapital arbeit tausch und alkohol nation
ok dann stellt sich die frage wer kann
oder was sind die einwände
also es muss schon betont werden auch
wenn wenn er das habe ich schon gedacht
aber ich würde es nochmal wiederholen
adam smith wird oft angeführt als ein
heilloser vertreter dass der
ausbeuterischen bourgeoisie oder was
auch immer also definitiv ein
unmenschlicher feind oder irgendwas das
ist er auf keinen fall also wie ich
schon gesagt habe
erstens ist
ein sehr interessanter und sehr humana
viele moralphilosoph in seiner seiner
arbeit über über moralische empfindungen
und zweitens ist auch das werk über die
wohlstand der nationen auch ein rest
bayerisches werk also er hat schon im
auge dass es der menschheit besser gehen
sollte es sind elemente drin wichtige
elemente die werden wir nicht ausblenden
die man heutzutage schon bedenklich
finden würde aber smith und wie schon
gesagt mehr und lockt sowieso sind alle
aufklärer aufklärer in dienste eines
eines besseren lebens also was sind dann
die einwände oder die einschränkungen
die sich ergeben können
tatsächlich ergeben oder oder weiterhin
ergeben kann also bei wie vor das sagen
das sind dafür die als erster
entscheidender erster kritikpunkt der
von smith selbst ins feld gebracht wird
ist dass die kapitalbildung was ja an
sich was positives ist weil wir mit mit
kapital erzeugen und und entwickeln
können
das verhindert wird also kapital
entsteht nicht quasi passive setzt
voraus dass die menschen sich da lebhaft
dafür einsetzen und es wird oft
verhindert insbesondere durch den adel
der auf seinen ländereien sitzt
rohmaterialien dadurch bindet und nichts
tut außer konsumieren was unterscheidet
sehr stark zwischen produktiver arbeit
und konsum und wenn der mensch nur das
konsumiert aber nur soweit erzeugt oder
arbeitet wie er für seinen unmittelbar
konsum braucht dann ist das was deutlich
negatives der erde ist da noch schlimmer
weil der abend aus sei es mit sich dass
konsumiert was andere nämlich die die
ist eine pächter erzeugen also es ist in
der bilanz vollständig negativ er
kritisiert natürlich adelige
großgrundbesitzer die sich
beispielsweise nicht informieren die man
mit der modernen agrarwirtschaft umgehen
könnte wie sie wissen also dass im 18
jahrhundert sind wichtige reformen
aufgetreten die die ganze landwirtschaft
revolutioniert haben
ob das jetzt der heutigen perspektive
unbedingt ein ungeteiltes sehen ist es
eine andere frage aber jedenfalls war es
so dass das die vorstellung man kann
grund und boden weiterentwickelt und zu
einem kapital halb am rande und das ist
etwas was im achtzehnten jahrhundert zur
miss zeiten sehr wichtig war und er das
gefühl dass das die verschwenderischen
adeligen einfach auf ihren gütern sitzen
und und dass diese entwicklung nicht
mitmachen war eine starke polemik nicht
nur weil es mit ok wie gesagt das
problem ist dass dadurch verhindert wird
dass das grund und boden zu kapital wird
grund und boden sind nur dann kapital
wenn sie sich für produktion eignen
am besten für produktion das über die
unmittelbaren konsumbedürfnisse
hinausgeht
also wenn ich jetzt güter und ländereien
haben kann ich natürlich jagen ich kann
hirscher erlegen und so weiter und die
verspeisen und auch äpfel oder was auch
immer das daher so spontan und frei und
wild wächst aber das ist alles nur
konsum ich ändere daran nichts
und das ist etwas was aus als mit
perspektive etwas was nur negatives ist
also da wird er auch relativ polemisch
dagegen bestandteil davon und das ist
etwas was in all diesen denkern diesen
früheren denkern deutliches thema wird
ist smith attackiert die erbfolge
regelungen die damals in england
dominierten nämlich wir heißen dass
überhaupt auf deutsch also dass der
erstgeborene wesentlichen alles erbt
prime manager horst es auf englisch und
das sagt er
also das ist das ist falsch und es noch
schlimmer wird es durch das englisches
system von das heißt es
das ist eine juristische konstruktion in
etwa eine stiftung
also was was die großen adelsfamilien
damals gemacht haben ist sie haben das
gesamte vermögen in eine stiftung
eingebracht und die stiftung hatte dann
quasi ein ewiges leben und deswegen
konnten konnte das vermögen der familie
zusammengehalten werden weil jeder
einzelne vertreter sei er noch so
verschwenderisch und
verrufen und die so lud konnte an das
vermögen nicht ran sondern nur die
einkünfte daraus erhalten ja also die
familien das werden es sind in
familienstiftungen die theoretisch
uneingeschränkt lange existieren können
also wenn das ist ja ist es
offensichtlich warum dass es sich
negativ ist ein paar das beispiel was
besser wäre aus sagen dass ich wenn man
diese stiftungen nicht zulässt dann
gehört das vermögen dann einer jeweils
einer bestimmten person konkreten person
also dem erben und wie man weiß eben
entweder weise selber verschwenderisch
sind oder weil sie kindern keine kinder
kriegen oder egal was wenn wenn es im
eigentum einer einzelnen person stehe
ins das vermögen dann ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass das vermögen
dadurch zerstreut wird viel höher und
das ist was gutes also für smith ist
quasi eine akkumulation über
generationen hinweg ungefähr das
schlimmste was man haben könnte das ist
das ist etwas was die kapitalbildung vor
allem verhindert und deswegen kritisiert
er immer wieder diese endlos diese
stiftung für uns ist das vielleicht ja
gut
eigentlich ist das immer noch aktuell in
der juristerei gibt es viele kollegen
die sehr viel geld verdienen indem sie
familienstiftungen errichten immer noch
also es ist nicht mehr ganz so einfach
also die englische regel ist das meine
stiftung nicht länger dauern darf es ein
leben in existence also ein jetzt
existierendes lebenden plus ich glaube
50 jahre oder weniger ich weiß es nicht
also das würde dann heißen also
angenommen
ich hätte ein enkelkind könnte ich sagen
dass diese stiftung dauert so lange wie
mein enkel noch am leben ist und dann
noch mal 50 jahre und danach muss es
aufgelöst werden
ja ich habe keinen enkel und kein
vermögen das ist verärgert aber wenn ich
das hätte könnte ich das
familienvermögen wenigstens so lange
zusammen halten aber danach muss es
aufgelöst werden
und das hätte dann zur folge dass in was
weiß ich etwa 100 jahren ist dann wieder
konkrete liebe hinter personen keine
abstrakte stiftung mehr ist und dann
biologische menschen die dann das
eigentum übernehmen und dann ist die
erwartung ja die werden wie man so was
mit menschen die werden es irgendwie
dann doch verprassen und ausgeben also
das ist das ist die die regel ich glaube
so viel ich weiß aber ich bin kein
experte auf dem gebiet
es gibt schon zahlreiche möglichkeiten
wie ich das vermeiden kann
wahrscheinlich hat es mit den cayman
inseln oder irgendwas zu tun weiß es
nicht aber jedenfalls ist ist diese
debatte über lang währende stiftung an
etwas eine ziemlich klassische sache die
immer noch bei den großen familien
aktuell ist
[Musik]
ja das ist dass er ist in der tat das
ist dann kein kapital
ja also dazu werden wir noch kommen aber
wichtig bei kapital soll ich jetzt erst
mal vorab ist es zirkulieren
es muss zirkulieren also sonst wird kein
gewinn ab und dann ist es egal aus
welcher sich man das sieht es das
schlecht aber der andere punkt das ganz
kurz die frage war ob es mit weiß
dagegen hat dass die adeligen das
einfach ohne eigene arbeit
er wird oder erhalten haben ganz wichtig
weil es mit aber das wird dazu werden
wir nach kommt also zu diesen ganzen die
denken die man die marx ist bürgerlich
abgetan hätte ist dass sie sehr stark
sicher den schutz des eigentums
einsetzen
ja also es ist ein bisschen wie die
debatte jetzt ob man den vermieter und
eigenen leute im großen stil also wenn
man das richtig revolutionär anpacken
dann enteignet man sich schlicht und
einfach aber natürlich gesetzlich muss
man sie entschädigen
und diese frage mit oder ohne
entschädigung ist im hintergrund immer
eine frage aber für smes für diese
ganzen bürgerlichen denke für smith und
für müll und co und eigene fehler recht
aber definitiv noch mit entschädigung
geschmackssache
zunächst mal aber die frage ob es jetzt
morales schön ist dass irgendwelche
adeligen alleine durch den zufall der
geburt sehr viel reicher sind als alle
anderen ok mag schon sein aber
vorrang hatte schutz des eigentums aber
dazu ist noch was zu sagen wo es kommt
alles okay gut also dass ist jetzt mit
und und insgesamt mit familienstiftungen
zweiter punkt und das ist jetzt das ist
vielleicht beschränkt sich mehr auf
ältere debatten die heutzutage nicht
mehr ganz so aktuell sind da wird jetzt
heute punkt ist natürlich der klassische
einwand gegen gegen kapitalismus nämlich
dass akkumulation zum konzentration
führt also man hat diese spannung auf
der einen seite ist akkumulation
voraussetzungen gemäß weil es gut ist
also wenn ihr akkumulieren kann man da
haben wir was womit wir was machen
können können dann wunderbare große
fabriken und so weiter gründen und damit
fantastische maschinen und allen geht es
dadurch besser aber das problem mit mit
dieser dynamik ist dass es dazu tendiert
zu dass es zur konzentration tendiert
konzentration und monopolbildung ja das
ist etwas wenn er das stehe ich erstmal
in den in den raum
aber das ist in vielerlei hinsichten
auch noch heute die große frage also wie
kann man einerseits den menschen oder
die in den aktions trieb der menschen
freien lauf lassen und das eigentlich
eigentlich gut ist aber gleichzeitig
verhindern dass die menschen dass einige
wenige das ganze erzeugte reichtum damit
dann abschöpfen
also dazu noch ganz kurz beim also dazu
sind wir noch nicht gekommen quasi
historisch aber trotzdem bei mir diese
frage in der debatte über die damalige
kooperative
das war ein gesamteuropäisches phänomen
mitte des 19 jahrhunderts und die die
frage war die hoffnung mail hat das sehr
stark unterstützt
dass die arbeit ihr eigenes kapital
verschaffen können einfach indem sie
sich zusammentun und durch entbehrungen
und sparen und was auch immer genug
kapital zusammen kriegen dass sie dann
mit den eigentlichen bürgerlichen
kapitalisten konkurrieren können
das war mills idee also wie gesagt
mailings linksliberal und dem sinne
er war sagt also dass an dem sozialismus
sein sollen begriff was er unterstützen
kann ist dieser gedanke dass die arbeit
der sich in kooperativen verdienten
selber ihr kapital
okay das verhindert haben meine dieses
dieses problem mit mit der dynamik der
akkumulation der falschen der
kombination hat mir ausdrücklich
angesprochen und seine antwort war wie
gesagt naja steht eigentlich jedem frei
oder jedem jeder gruppe frei selber ihr
kapital zu erschaffen
ja okay gut also vielleicht vielleicht
nicht aber das ist das ist das dass das
ein problem ist war steht es ist für
mich schon deutlich also was mir zeigen
wie weniger ich glaube die problematik
der ungezügelten kumulation ist bei
smith spielt es keine rolle
noch keine rolle also das ist dann eine
lösung weil die kooperative bewegung das
für ihn und für ihn war dass die zukunft
das war nicht nur ja wir können mal die
sind gegen steuern indem man ihr
kooperieren das war ein modell für die
zukunft also genau wie marx dachte
und das ist jetzt der nächste bond marx
dachte wir brauchen eine revolution und
da werden alle eigentumsverhältnisse um
gewählt also der das bürgertum wird im
wesentlichen enteignet ob mit oder ohne
entschädigung ist nicht ganz so deutlich
aber wahrscheinlich eher ohne und das
ist verhindert dann oder es mag dann
schon sein dass wir da eine
konzentration von kapital haben aber
wenn das kapital dem dem volk gehört
dann ist das auch nicht mehr schädlich
marxens gedanke dritter punkt also wo
diese bei marx ist die konzentration bei
den bei den großen bürgern großbürgertum
bei der porsche se und die wären dann
das wird dann gewinnt eventuell zu
enteignen jetzt heute im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert haben wir
diese debatte weiter hinten und der
wichtigsten vertreter oder an ein
einflussreicher vertreter in der letzten
zeit ist ist lte den sie möglicherweise
gelesen haben also peak etikette ist es
auch das problem also mehrfache probleme
die pipette aufgreift das eine ist das
kapital mehr profit abwirft als arbeit
also wissen sie wahrscheinlich schon
also das problem bei dass bp anpacken
wer ist dass die kapitalisten immer
reicher werden also unter normalen
umständen wenn man nichts dagegen
unternimmt wird werden die kapitalisten
im bereich also die besitzer von kapital
werden zwangsläufig einfach durch die
gesetzmäßigkeiten die pipette feststellt
statistisch der besitzer von kapital
wird immer schneller reicher als
derjenige der arbeitet also der normale
arbeiten
normale angestellte
kann nie so viel verdienen auch wenn ein
sehr hoher angestellter ist bei google
oder sonstwo wenn er kein kapital hat
kann er nie schritt halten mit den
kapitaleignern ja okay das ist peek at
ease punkt aber gleichzeitig auch dass
ein teil des problems ist auch die
akkumulation des kapitals ist auch bei
gerade bei pwc
also das ist die kapitalisten
akkumulieren nicht nur sondern auch das
heißt sie dann haben ist auch mehr
erträglich als das was wir die nicht
kapitalisten haben ja das ist ein
französischer ökonomen ich habe es eine
heisse thomas thomas betätigt und das
sein das buch heißt kapital
gewissermaßen eine provokation und ist
ich glaube 2014 ungefähr also dass sie
wird von allen gelesen auch von von den
journalisten der financial times und the
world und ist also die deutsche
übersetzung kenne ich nicht die
englische ist super es kann man kann es
wirklich im bett vorm schlafengehen
lesen
es ist sehr schön geschrieben und viele
sehr anekdotenreich kann ich empfehlen
aber es hat nicht allzu viel mit
philosophie zu tun deswegen ist es nicht
zentraler gegenstand von dieser
vorlesung
er ist wirtschaftsprofessor ja okay also
dass konzentration auf seinem in seiner
höchsten entwicklung wie wir natürlich
wissen dieses monopol bildern und dass
monopole schlecht sind das wusste auch
schon smith also monopolisierung ist mit
einwand unter anderem gegen die
grossgrundbesitzer ist dass das effektiv
auch ein monopolist also wenn ich das
ganze grund besitze in einem in einer
gegend dann ist das habe ich im monopol
mit diesem land also das ist auch eine
etwas einfachere neben einem monopol im
20ten 21ten jahrhunderts ist die
monopolbildung noch viel deutlicher wie
wir wissen also die normalerweise hat
man hat die politik auch die bürgerliche
politik gegen monopolbildung maßnahmen
ergriffen wie beispielsweise tnt die
große amerikanische telekommunikations
firma die die zerschlagen wurde
oder stand noch ein bisschen früher und
das haben wir auch in der eu mit der
frau fest die festtage
ok also das ist jetzt ein betriebs
problem innerhalb des kapitalismus aber
ein wichtiger gegenstände auch heute
sind natürlich auch google ist ein
riesen monopol scheinbar aber dazu
wollte ich später noch was sein
ein weiterer punkt über die akkumulation
was vielleicht weniger angesprochen wird
aber
für viele eine eine sehr wichtige rolle
gespielt hat in den letzten zehn jahren
seit der finanzkrise ist der finanzmarkt
besonders hell finanz mal für derivate
weil derivate oder swaps oder wie man
sie also in welcher in welcher form auch
immer sie auftreten sind wetten im
wesentlichen und zwar wetten ohne
konkreten einsatz weiß nicht wen sie
sich da auskennen aber das ist eine
normalerweise wenn ich eine wette ab
gebe im wettbüro da muss ich auf den
tisch legen
ja ich muss bezahlen oder im kasino ich
kann nicht im casino einfach solcher du
kriegst es schon irgendwann ich muss vor
vorneweg geld auf den tisch legen
das ist bei swaps und derivaten nicht
der fall das ist wirklich so ja gut also
ich sage ich behaupte mal wenn ich
verliere kriegst du irgendwas wir wissen
zwar nicht wie viel das sein wird und
das geld wirklich erstmal nicht auf dem
tisch aber wir gehen davon aus dass sich
das zahlen kann und das ist eine große
illusion dass dessen grund warum dieses
hop so gefährlich sind und das problem
ist dass durch solche geschäft praktisch
enorme enteignungen stattfinden und dass
auch beispielsweise bei gemeinden
kommunen
das ist vor allem in amerika ein paar in
den usa ein problem gewesen aber nicht
nur
auch in deutschland haben gemeinde hin
viel geld verloren und das die folge ist
also jetzt weniger mit den gemeinden
arbeiten mit banken beispielsweise
erster instanz wurde praktisch von den
anderen banken rivalen geschluckt wegen
dieser
unvorsichtig abgeschlossenen derivaten
und das ist eine form von konzentration
denn eine bank eine andere bank schluckt
einfach wegen derivatgeschäfte dann
konzentriert natürlich die bank die da
gewinnt sehr viel eigentum und reichtum
auf sich was na ja gut es ist
konzentration und gefährliche
konzentration und sehr sehr schädliche
konnte konzentration okay das jetzt nur
als anekdote nebenbei aber konzentration
ist wirklich ein sehr konkretes problem
dass viel mehr betrifft als nur große
monopolistische gesellschaften also wenn
es eine gemeinde betrifft dann trifft es
uns alle
also sofern wir in der jeweiligen
kommune leben
ok gut also dass ist der zweite der
erste punkt war einwände gegen
beispielsweise uneingeschränkte zeitlich
und eingeschränktes
eigentumsverhältnisse weil das die
kapitalbildung im keim erstickt zweiter
punkt ist die akkumulation haben wir
gerade besprochen
der dritte punkt das ist die alle zum
beispiel auch die allmend
problematisch ist dass gegenstände ins
kapital eigenkapital verwandelt werden
die eigentlich gar nicht dorthin gehören
also es gibt es gibt werte oder
gegenstände die man als kapital
behandeln kann die aber nicht als
kapital betrachtet werden sollte und das
erste beispiel was auch von von all
diesen auch den bürgerlichen denkens
attackiert wurde ist natürlich die
sklaverei also in der sklaverei wird
werden menschen zu kapital also
gewissermaßen sind sind qualifizierte
arbeit kann man auch als kapital
betrachtet aber das geht noch klar da
wird er ganz der ganze mensch als als
eigentum und als kapital behandelt bei
peek at t beispielsweise gibt es da sehr
schöne grafische darstellung wonach in
den südstaaten der usa vor dem
bürgerkrieg war dass sie waren erstens
sehr reich also die heutzutage denkt man
ja die südstaaten in amerika das sind
diese armen leute die im wohnwagen
trailer wohnen aber historisch ist das
nicht so
also die die die südstaaten waren sehr
viel reicher ist die nordstaaten bei
beginnt es zu beginn des bürgerkriegs
und das lag zu einem sehr großen teil an
dem klaren die ungefähr ein drittel von
dem gesamten kapital
da stellt man muss sich diese grafiken
angucken bei petit aber das sind des
menschen werden dann zu kapital
also arbeiter sind bayerischen anderes
thema das ist der erste einfach der
zweite bereich der aus bei vielen dieser
denke nicht als kapital behandelt werden
darf und das ist ein bisschen das thema
das letzte woche schon hatten ist grund
und boden also auch diese bürgerlichen
denker waren der meinung dass boden an
sich nicht kapital ist also ist darf
nicht in kapital mäßiges eigentum
überführt werden sondern wir das hat mir
ja schon bei lok so lockt sagt mir
gehört der boden so weit ich ihn
bearbeiten kann uns mehr ist als das
dann gehört er mir nicht das sagen auch
die die nachfolge aus mails und mill
das ist sehr beispiels also mills thema
ist beispielsweise sehr fraglich ob man
den grund und boden überhaupt vererben
darf also solange ich da bin und boden
verarbeite ist es okay aber wieso soll
warum wieso kann ich dir unterboden dann
vererben
das ist die das ist die frage grund und
boden wird gesagt wird was sicherlich
auch stimmt ist gewissermaßen unser
allem gegeben als menschen also der
mensch erhält oder lebt auf grund und
boden von natur her
es ist nicht etwas was automatisch und
selbstverständlich in eigentum überführt
werden sollte jedenfalls nicht abstrakt
also das ist etwas vielleicht eben
vielleicht nicht vielleicht werden wir
dem zustimmen oder nicht marx sagte
ausdrücklich dass boden im eigenen nicht
im eigentum nicht in privateigentum
bleiben sollte und das ist etwas wo
himmel eigentlich
sich diesem standpunkt auch nähert also
was mir authentisch gehört vielleicht
mein wohnhaus darf ich also verschenken
darf ich vielleicht auch vererben
ja ja ja genau okay das ist dieses
monopol dieser monopole aspekt zu grund
und boden ist nicht beliebig vermehrbar
gut also was auch immer aber entweder
deswegen oder weil es einfach zu unserem
zu unserer zum allgemeinen naturerbe der
menschen gehört sowie luft und wasser
wobei das natürlich ein weiteres problem
ist aber dass also der weiter ist das
problem der commons oder der allmende
und das ist auch etwas was thematisiert
wird auch schon damals aber heute wissen
werden wird das immer gut damit wasser
und der fischerei auf hochsee und so
weiter und so fort
das ist etwas was auch bei diesen
bürgerlichen denkens nicht als selbst
eigentum an diesen elementen
privateigentum an diesen elementen wird
nicht selbstverständlich vorausgesetzt
es wird nicht großartig problematisiert
aber der gedanke dass nicht alles in
eigentum überführt werden darf ist schon
selbstverständlich damals ja also
primates der arbeit und dass ich nicht
bearbeiten kann darf mir auch nicht
gehören
und wenn es uns allen gehört darf ich
auch nicht zum schaden anderer etwas für
mich in anspruch nehmen was ich nicht
nutzen kann und das ja vielleicht
erfasst das auch
fische und wasser wahrscheinlich würde
dieses thema lieber ein bisschen
ausklammern
das führt für meine zwecke bis hin zu
weit aber das ist jedenfalls ein
beispiel dafür
ein weiteres beispiel für elemente die
gar nicht kapitalisiert werden dürfen
schließlich dann werfe ich noch eines
quasi aktuelle fragesteller sind
persönliche daten also die jetzt haben
wir und die eu hat wie sie wissen eine
datenschutz grundordnung eingeführt die
mehr oder weniger gesagt hat das gehört
euch nicht also wenn privat privatleute
persönliche daten abgreifen wollen dann
nur mit zustimmung des betroffenen ob
das funktioniert oder nicht bleibt auch
abzuwarten aber das gesamte
geschäftsmodell wie wir wissen von
google beruht darauf dass diese elemente
private daten unentgeltlich abgegriffen
werden und vielleicht gehören sie nicht
zum kapital
sie werden als kapital verwenden aber
man könnte sagen dass sie eigentlich
nicht zum kapital gehören okay das lasse
ich erstmal offen
können wir uns noch überlegen aber es
ist ein weiteres beispiel für etwas was
schon damals in den ursprüngen
diskutiert wurde nicht alles eignet sich
als kapital
schließlich führte kategorie von
einwänden oder kritikpunkten gegen
gegenüber
dem kapitalismus ist die ganze
problematik des falschen bewusst so
eines das kennen wir natürlich
hauptsächlich bei marx oder unmittelbar
ist das etwas worüber markt spricht also
falsches bewusstsein ist wenn der mensch
zum riechen oder tendenziösen
ergebnissen kommt wegen wegen der
wirtschaftlichen interessen entweder
seine eigenen oder von anderen personen
die in diese diese falschen inhalte
aufdrücken
also das ist etwas was das habe ich auch
schon gesagt das ist etwas was eben
zwanzigsten jahrhundert sehr betont wird
bei marx und gewissermaßen auch bei den
früheren also ideologie sagen wir mal
ist bei allen auch schon bei smith ein
wichtiges thema smith bringt das
allerdings weniger im zusammenhang mit
kapital oder sonst heißt also die fans
sind die adeligen foul
und deswegen ist das schlecht aber das
ist nicht unbedingt ideologie was er
dann aber sehr deutlich attackiert und
sein buch erreichung der nation dann ist
dafür unter anderem auch zelebriert er
attackiert die damaligen erziehungs
institute also vor allem die
universitäten und sagte die
universitäten bringen gar nichts sie
sind korrupt aus also bildung ist besser
sie dem einzelnen überlassen durch
solche sachen also was wir heutzutage
nur einen großen einschränkungen
akzeptieren würden aber die thematik es
gibt hier falsches bewusstsein das wird
von den etablierten institutionen
gefördert
das gibt schon weiß mehr ist im fünften
buch also wenn sie da rein schauen
wollen das ist schon ganz lustig wie er
gegen die universitäten polemisiert
bei marx ist das natürlich ein teil des
systems also für marx ist die ideologie
oder das falsche bewusstsein aus dem aus
den interessen des der kapitalisten
entspringt die kapitalisten nutzen
beispielsweise die religion aus und die
arbeiter zu unterdrücken oder ihr
bewusstsein ihres eigenen interessen zu
unterdrücken
das kennen wir allerdings ist es erst im
zwanzigsten jahrhundert dass der gedanke
hoch kommt ja vielleicht sollte man um
sich zu befreien
am anderen ende an setzen also mag sagt
falsches bewusstsein ist teil des
überbaus und wird bestimmt durch die
wirtschaftliche basis ist also es ist
einfach so wenig kapital ist bin habe
ich bestimmte interessen und naja das
ist interessiert sich wenig hier das
bewusstsein der kapitalisten marx
interessiert sich für das bewusstsein
der arbeiter und das hat dieses
bewusstsein dieses falsche bewusstsein
entspringt meinem unterworfen verhältnis
zu dem zum kapital aber dann
interessiert das eigentlich nicht mehr
so sonderlich
mein mann hat im zwanzigsten jahrhundert
wahrscheinlich wissen aus dem ersten
band von kapital
diese diesem gefeierten passus über über
den war waren fertig ist muss raus
geholt
aber das ist mehr für marx selbst ist
das meer so ein exkurs sondern 70 kurs
exkurs es ist gehört nicht zum wesen
seines systems also dazu steht also wenn
sie wenn ihnen das nicht sagt nichts
sagt ist das nicht so schlimm das werden
wir später besprechen
aber das ist dann im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert wird das umgekehrt
und da fängt die diskussion an inwiefern
der bestimmt die ideologie die basis ist
also marx ging davon aus dass basis den
überbau bestimmt im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert fängt man uns überlegen ja
vielleicht ist irgendwas an dem überbau
nicht in ordnung was zu diesen negativen
ergebnissen in der basis in der
wirtschaftlichen basis führt und da das
hängt weiß nicht ob sie mit ihm anfängt
aber ein wichtiges beispiel ist
natürlich max weber zudem wir später
kommen werden
max weber sagt mehr oder weniger ja das
sind diese calvinisten die dieses diesen
kapitalismus forciert haben
und es gibt romane religionen ist
jedenfalls die implikation und das wäre
dann ein möglicher ausweg aus diesem
falschen bewusstsein ja vielleicht eine
möglichkeit also weber ist da schon eher
auf der bürgerlichen seite in der
nachfolge kommen dann viel härtere
marxistische ansätze die sehr stark
maxence betonung des proletariats und
des politischen bewusstseins aufgreifen
und das sind dann lukas und naja weniger
die frankfurter schule vielleicht aber
lukac auf jeden fall also lukas idee wie
sie wahrscheinlich wissen ist es dass
das bewusstsein der menschheit unter
kapitalismus weitgehend datiert ist und
da daraus muss man ausbrechen
und wenn man das bewusstsein das
historische bewusstsein oder historisch
entscheidende bewusstsein des
proletariats verwirklicht hat dann dann
erst werden wir in freiheit
also das ist jetzt hat für lukas
irgendwie schon vorrang vor einen
pragmatischen wirtschaftlichen maßnahmen
und der die dritte reaktion auch in
diesem rahmen hat das haben wir uns also
adorno als gewissermaßen beeinflusst von
lokalen wir uns noch anschauen und
schließlich habermas der nachkriegs
gebrauch cabanas stark beeinflusst meine
richtigen sächsische philosophie zum
anderen durch psychologische oder
psychologische bewegungen in deutschland
wie alexander mitscherlich hat einen
etwas anderen ansatz also weg von
polizeirat und klassenkampf weiter heben
zum gedanken da das werden wir unsere
kommunikation so quasi bereinigen
könnten wenn der mensch nur hohle hand
von mensch zu mensch dialoge entfalten
könnte dann hätten wir würden wir von
von den und von kapitalismus als von den
von den negativen elementen des
kapitalismus befreien
ok also das wie gesagt alles als kosten
ab als überblick über die möglichen
kategorien von einwänden gegen den
kapitalismus noch mal ganz kurz also
erstens das aber das ist jetzt kein
anleihen gegen den kapitalismus sondern
einwand gegen früheren
in einem früheren stadium des
kapitalismus nämlich der einwurf dass
die kapitalbildung überhaupt verhindert
wird durch konsumierende adelige über
die brauchen wir uns heutzutage oder ich
weiß es nicht vielleicht ist das wird
dass sie jetzt wieder zu einem problem
weiß ich nicht aber jedenfalls dass das
ist die älteste und möglicherweise uns
wenig am wenigsten aktuelle dings
weniger am wenigsten aktueller
kritikpunkt zweitens ist die klassische
der klassische einwand der akkumulation
monopolbildung drittens die falsche für
kapitalisierung von sachen die gar nicht
zum kapital gehören und viertens der
einwand des kapitalismus zu falsche
bewusstsein führt oder zumindest metall
oder möglicherweise auch von falschen
bewusstsein verursacht wird aber
jedenfalls eng mit falschen bewusstsein
verknüpft wird
ok also das ist der überblick den ich
heute bringen wollte bevor wir mit marx
und den späteren denken weitermachen
wollte ich schon noch ein bisschen was
zu mir sagen und dann werden wir sehen
ich würde noch erwähnen die ob sie ihnen
hilft oder nicht das müssen sie selber
beurteilen aber im zuge meiner
überlegungen habe ich aus diesen texten
ziemlich viele extrakt rausgeholt und
auf die website gesetzt
also ich beziehe mich auf zitate und
quellen und so weiter diese zitaten und
zitate und quellen werden sie finden auf
der uni website ich weiß ja haben sie
die webseite gefunden ja
[Musik]
und vielleicht hilft ihnen das
vielleicht nicht aber jedenfalls quasi
das ist dass sich die struktur die ich
verwende wenn ich nicht behauptungen
aufstelle dann ist das meine sind das
meine beweise okay gut jetzt sind sie
dran